vice president kamala harris being
mocked once again for another doozy of a
word salad statement this time kamala
was giving a speech about affordable
internet access
by the significance of the passage of
time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time in terms of what we need to do to
lay these wires what we need to do to
create these jobs and there is such
great significance to the passage of
time
but the vp's problems don't end there a
new book revealing a feud between harris
and the white house with biden's
communication director reportedly
blaming the vp for her missteps and
toxic work environment and not the tough
assignments she's been given
okay now i suspect greg that you
understood that word salad because i
didn't get it you know what's funny if i
didn't know any better better i would
think that she took a bong hit except
she lacks the depth of a competent
stoner it was as if she read the
transcript of a robot pretending to be
high right she has this amazing thought
in her head and there's this incredible
gulf between what she believes in her
head to be awesome and then what
everybody hears which is nonsense she
doesn't know there's a she doesn't know
how it sounds but she deserves credit
for one thing she lost her tenth staffer
which means she's just completed the
staff punch card which entitles her to
firing an 11th staffer at no extra cost
you know what we can't have someone on
the international stage you know whether
it's about the border or ukraine i mean
the woman couldn't even answer a
question as to whether or not we take
refugees jessica yes
let's just say my name for 30 seconds
um
that was
true he got a present uh being on the
stage with the president of poland when
he's facing he had like three million
refugees show up in one day and that unc
the uncomfortable laugh which obviously
has become a bit of a running joke about
her was definitely more upsetting to me
than this passage of time quote but
there's there's no question that there's
an issue here um her popularity is it's
low it's well below joe biden's and what
i have heard in defense of these
staffers that are leaving it's not that
these staffers are not qualified
apparently there's a refusal to read the
briefing books
as completely
as you should before you go out there
and give these kinds of press
conferences or meeting with other world
officials and so i
i feel for them and there is natural
turnover and we all know that and so not
everyone is leaving because they you
know they hate it and they need new
opportunities and campaign cycles etc
but there's no question that it is very
believable that biden's people and
harris's people are at odds with one
another
jesse you want to talk about the palace
intrigue about biden's people and
harris's people well i found out that dr
jill doesn't like harris and i know if
your wife doesn't like someone that
you're friends with tell me about it
that's done that is officially done
i did some estate planning and you know
you got to set things up for your spouse
or your children in case god forbid i
get stabbed by a vicious homeless man
not out of the realm of possibility it's
cut it's happened and it's about
protecting the people that you love in
case something horrible goes wrong
and joe biden is an older guy he's
almost 80 years old and when you pick a
vice president it's almost like you're
doing estate planning you know you have
to protect the country if god forbid
anything happened to you so the fact
that joe biden selected kamala tells me
he didn't do any estate planning and he
doesn't care actually about the country
as much as he should because to leave
america in her hands if god forbid
something happened to joe would be
beyond a dereliction of duty now
i have to assume that that was a
teleprompter glitch
because
judge why did she just repeat the phrase
six times
she has to be just reading the phrase
over and over again until in the
teleprompter it's not the first time she
repeated a phrase over and over
that was not a teleprompter
so she
i thought this is ron
no i thought she was ron bergen being it
and she was just reading what was in
front of her over and over right wow
okay i'm trying to give her the benefit
of it
you know what i think i think that joe
biden really did do some estate planning
because she's his insurance
policy no one is going to look to get
rid of joe biden because they know what
they're going to get if the by way of
impeachment so it made him look better
yeah yeah well you know that's actually
very i don't think that much strategy
went into this no i think that we all
know what happened um when he was
deciding who he wanted and he said okay
look he didn't look at her and say she
would be the best counselor for me when
i'm in the middle of a big decision
she's going to be the best person for me
to go out on the stump and give a great
speech now they patched up the after
that um debate where she basically
called him a racist that's why dr jill
biden has never really forgiven her for
that but also um you cannot she wants to
be president
and you cannot bluff your way through
the vice presidency and
extemporaneous speaking on the when i
was on the speech team you have to fill
a you have to do a five to seven minute
speech and it feels to me like she's
trying to get to that seventh minute by
adding all sorts of words that don't
even make any sense the other thing i
would like to do is to say let me give
her the benefit of the doubt on
something as well
they have set her up with three things
in the recent memory that did not work
out so they told her go fix voting
rights they gave her no evidence that
there was voting rights problems that
she could turn to and they never were
going to have the votes so they gave her
a mission that she was going to fail at
on the border they didn't give her any
policy change recommendations that she
could go forward with so she was like
okay actually i'll just go do
root causes down in central america and
the third thing is they went to poland
and she didn't have a deliverable so if
i were the chief of staff for the
president i would try to figure out what
my problem is to try to help her all
right
ahead car free sundays the insane new
ideas liberals are pushing to counter
surging gas prices